we wanted to interrupt that hearing for
just a minute to bring in
hhs secretary alex azar so mr secretary
thank you so much i know that it was
just six months ago that operation
warp speed got underway and i think we
should take a moment to celebrate
the innovation of these scientists both
here in america and in the partners that
these
companies have absolutely you know
america's great biopharmaceutical
industry deserves credit but
i got to say president trump deserves
the credit for for
basically conceiving of the possibility
the vision that we could get a vaccine
within a year and instead we have it
within 10 months
of a novel pathogen coming to the united
states and dana as you mentioned
these aren't just any ordinary vaccines
thanks to operation warp speeds effort
and the the effort to scale up
manufacturing and run these
comprehensive 30
000 person plus clinical trials these
are over 90
effective vaccines i mean this is big
news it is and i also wonder about this
so
you have the two companies maybe more
right are going to have effective
vaccines that the government will say
okay we're going to work on this
how do you figure out a way to mass
produce enough because
10 million doses 20 million doses that's
not enough to get everybody taken care
of
how does that work do they have to pull
resources and share information
so this was actually the genius of what
we built in operation warp speed we
literally began making these doses or
paying to make those doses
even as we were testing to see if they
would work so we already have stockpiled
many millions of doses of both vaccines
we're manufacturing four other max of
the vaccines that are in operation warp
speed
that's what's going to enable us from
moderna and pfizer if they get fda
authorization we believe we'll have as
many as 40 million approved releasable
doses
by the end of december uh so and then
it'll just keep going month
after month more production more
qualification like that
and so we and we know that there are you
know the tiers of who should get it
first but
certainly of course healthcare workers
we need to make sure that they're taken
care of and the vulnerable and i think
that
you've already um figured that out but
if i could use um
my mom as an example okay so um early
70s
denver colorado very much wants to get
back to her
life and at this point how does she
choose
who to call in order to try to get in
line to get the vaccine
which vaccine to get how would that work
for somebody because i think now that
it's
more real and it looks like we will have
this vaccine now you get down to the
nitty-gritty of how do you get it done
yeah so we'll be in a very controlled
distribution approach as we have more
limited supplies in the first couple of
months and we'll be focused on
the prioritized groups of those most
vulnerable as well as those most able to
benefit so you mentioned a couple of
them are
healthcare workers emergency first
responders but then are most vulnerable
so
individuals in nursing homes perhaps
assisted living we're going to look at
the data when it comes in
cdc will assess that and make
recommendations to our nation's
governors on where they'd like us to
send vaccine
but it'll be very controlled initially
with those limited supplies because we
just want to make sure
we get the biggest bang for the buck out
of every dose of vaccine save as many
lives as we possibly can early on so at
this point
like my mom should not call her doctor
or her pharmacy and sort of ask to be
put on a list for december 20th
that's right there's no waiting list or
program like that dana at this point
we'll be moving into that type of
general distribution as we move into the
months ahead but
initially it's going to be very focused
whether it's nursing homes assisted
living
health care workers emergency first
responders very tightly controlled
distribution system using america's
world leading commercial distribution
system that we use to get over 90
million
vaccines for children out every year
through cdc and over 170 million flu
vaccines every year
a tried and true system that we know
works right and we of course utilize all
of those assets to make that done
i actually participated in the pandemic
exercise in 2005.
and when they got to the part where
there was the distribution that was
actually one of the most interesting
things to me because
how you make those choices and how you
get it done it's obviously a super
important part of this
there's also a little bit of you know
politics going on we have
president-elect joe biden yesterday
suggesting that
if there's no coordination that more
people might die take a listen
more people may die if we don't
coordinate
if we have to wait until january 20th to
start that planning
it puts us behind over a month month and
a half
and so it's important that it be done
that there be coordination
now correct me if i'm wrong but
doesn't all of that planning continue
regardless
of this period i mean what you've said
is operation warp speed is in place for
all americans
as i understand it it would just
continue to move forward with no
interruption
that's absolutely right and you know
planning doesn't begin on january 20th
planning began many months ago
we put out over 64 pages of detailed
technical specs
to 64 states territories and local
jurisdictions
they've all submitted very comprehensive
distribution plans we've been working
back and forth with each one of them on
that
these are career people at cdc defense
department operation warp speed
that are working on that they continue
no matter what so there will always be
consistency and professionalism
the distribution program will go on
unabated and uninterrupted
secretary azar we appreciate you joining
us today and no doubt we'll be anxious
to talk to you in the future especially
my mom
thank you